okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
as usual i'm happy to try to answer
any questions simple or
seemingly complicated about science and
technology and mathematics and those
kinds of things
and
i'll do my best to uh
to
tell you what i think about different
kinds of things
so we have a few questions that i see
were left over from last time
there's one from mikhail here
are there any models that predict how
society behaves
all right that's kind of an interesting
question
um it's kind of
we have to
we have to look at different kinds of
scales and different kinds of uh
phenomena so for example let's say
you've got a city and you're looking at
the growth of the city well it's a good
beginning model that the city will grow
the outsides of the city will grow
further out and when there's a road it
will go around the road and so on
and it is possible to make pretty
reasonable models
that tell you sort of on average how a
city will grow
they won't tell you oh
in this particular place somebody's
going to build a road that's going to
cause people to go and
continue making subdivisions out in this
direction but they might tell you that
the the typical form of the growth of a
city is
things are randomly placed down on the
edge of the city in fact there's a
there's a well-known model that was
originally developed for uh well
originally developed actually for tumor
growth
and then has been used for many other
kind kinds of things it's kind of
aggregation model where you have a a
growing blob
and you say around the edge of the blob
let's let's add new lumps randomly at
different places around the edge of the
blob and that model predicts various
things about how you'll get some
tendrils that grow out and and you'll
get an average kind of roughness of the
surface and so on and that model does
sort of okay
at uh sort of on average saying how a
city will grow not telling you in
particular this particular city what
will happen in this particular place
now
you can
there are so that's that's sort of one
level of kinds of things that that
happen in modelling society if you look
at a an even smaller scale and you ask
about let's say road traffic flow there
are things you can say about oh a
traffic jam will tend to develop and and
as you as you go further and further
back in the traffic jam the average time
between stops and starts will increase i
think it's like the square root of the
distance from the front of the traffic
jam something like that and those are
things that you can work out
and that are sort of robustly true
independent of the details of oh this
particular person
uh
was faster at
putting their foot on the break than
this other person and so on
now if you ask about kind of larger
scale features of society there are
interesting issues there i mean for
example
the uh i don't know the hierarchical
organization
of
uh certain aspects of government or of
large organizations militaries things
like this
um i think there is
some evidence that
there are sort of general principles of
how people tend to organize themselves
that are sort of universal to the way
things work i mean it's kind of like in
a company um it's always a little hard
to tell with when you're doing these
societal kinds of things to what extent
is it everybody says a person should
have
managed you know 10 people and each of
those people could manage another 10
people and so on that people say that's
how it should work and therefore that's
how people set it up
or is it oh people kind of arrange
things based on how it seems to feel
right and so on and it ends up being
more or less that way
um it's hard to tell
which of those it is and which is is
because people think it's supposed to
work that way and which is because
that's sort of the natural way for
people to have it work
now if you look on a on a
still
oh if you if you ask questions about um
uh
things
i mean there are all kinds of detailed
models that people have
about uh different districts and if
they're people who
like uh you know who have this um
belief in this area and this belief in
this area and how will they tend to uh
sort of
uh you know where will they tend to live
based on the fact that they prefer to
live with people who agree with them in
this way or that way there are various
models actually based on these things
called cellular automata which i've
worked on a whole bunch there are
various models that people have made of
those kinds of of processes of
neighborhoods separating themselves into
you know everybody who likes this thing
is in this area everybody who likes that
thing is in that area how that comes to
be and so on and and again there's some
sort of average statistical regularity
to how that works even though the
particulars of oh does that mean so and
so is going you know such and such a
block in new york city is going to turn
into this or that
that's not the kind of thing that those
models can can tell on about
now
in um
you can also ask more global questions
you know what kind of theory could you
have about the the overall flow of
history so to speak
and you know people have had a variety
of kinds of theories like that sometimes
they kind of say look science is going
to prove history has to work this or
that way and then they tell people uh
you know so you should uh uh so let's
let's let's make it work that way
because science proves it has to work
that way i think generally that's not
been a very uh very sensible kind of set
of beliefs
but
you know you can ask questions about
whether it's inevitable that when
some society develops a certain amount
of bureaucracy then this will happen and
that will happen and you know you can
you can see certainly uh anecdotally one
can see
as uh sort of fields of endeavor get
larger they get more institutionalized
there's more structure things slow down
et cetera et cetera et cetera
whether that can be turned into
something that is
uh kind of a
a um
uh
a model maybe we should talk a little
bit about what the point of models is
so
in
there have been i think
maybe three maybe we're just introducing
a fourth
kind of general epoch in the history of
modeling of things
so back in you know ancient greek times
what did it mean to make a model of how
the world works
most of all it meant what's the world
made of
is it made of a bunch of atoms
is it made of everything is water or
something
underneath or you know what what are
things made of it's kind of the
structure of what's there
and then
the big innovation of the 1600s of
people like galileo and newton and so on
was actually there's another thing one
can do which is to use mathematics
mathematical equations to work out what
should happen in the world we have a an
equation that tells us
the
the the pattern the the geometrical
figure that the earth will make in going
around the sun things like that it will
go in an ellipse et cetera et cetera et
cetera um and that that one of the
features of that kind of mathematical
epoch
of modeling was
we can we can say we take things that we
see in the world and we turn them into a
mathematical formula and then one of the
things that we can do with that
mathematical formula is that formula
will be true for all time
and so so we can say well if we want to
know what will happen in the system if
we want to predict what will happen in
the system we just have to use that
formula and plug the appropriate number
for the time in and then get the result
so that kind of mathematical approach to
science led people to the idea that oh a
big part of the story of science is
about predicting things is about being
able to say
from what we know now what will happen
in the future
and those kinds of predictions mostly
are precise predictions that is
specifically it will rain tomorrow or
specifically this particular planet will
be in this particular position tomorrow
and so on
so that was kind of the idea of a lot of
modeling for a very long time
and clearly in things like will it rain
tomorrow that was a very challenging
area to be able to use kind of
mathematically inspired modeling to
predict but gradually over the course of
the last 60 years or so people have
gotten better at
running models of the atmosphere and
being able to work out you know what
will the weather be like but again it's
not so much um
uh roughly it's going to rain 20 of the
time to uh on this time of the year and
it's going to do this this percentage of
the time you actually want to know
specifically is it going to rain
tomorrow and even though there may be
some slight uncertainty in that the
fundamental objective of modeling is to
know with specificity is it going to
rain or not
okay
so
then the the kind of third epoch of kind
of making models in science
was one that i think really started in
earnest in the 1980s and i guess i i
take some credit for for having
initiated this
uh it was kind of the idea of don't use
mathematical formulas to describe how
the world works
instead say
things follow these particular rules
that can be represented as computer
programs if you run that program it will
behave in a way that corresponds to the
way that the world actually behaves
and
so that allows you to say
if you've got this uh
this set of rules that describe how a
snowflake grows you run that set of
rules as a program and then you make
these pictures and you say is that the
correct
description is that a correct
representation of how snowflakes grow or
not
so that's something which you might
think it's just like the mathematical
paradigm it's going to make precise
predictions in the same way and
sometimes it can but there's a very
important phenomenon that i found in the
in the 1980s a thing called
computational irreducibility
and so here's the here's the story
you say
okay you you say i managed to figure out
the rules by which the system operates
the precise way in which the components
of the system work and how they're
related to each other what they do
through time i've got a program that i
can just run that will reproduce what
the system does okay great
then that means you might think i can
predict everything about what the system
will do
well there's a catch
the problem is
that process of running the program you
might have to go through all the steps
that the program goes through to work
out what will the system do some amount
of time in the future
from the mathematical paradigm you kind
of have the idea i just plug a number
into a formula and i immediately jump
ahead and say what will
happen sometime in the future
but what happens in this computational
paradigm is this idea of computational
irreducibility that there can it can be
the case that to figure out what is
going to happen in the system you
basically have to follow each
computational step it's an irreducible
amount of computation that's involved in
figuring out what will happen
and that's kind of a very core
phenomenon of this kind of computational
paradigm and so it means that you can
have a situation where you can say well
yes i have a pretty good model for let's
say some aspect of how society works and
it's governed by these rules but if you
say well what's going to happen it may
be a case where you'd have to say well
i've got to run the computation to see
what will happen and really that's in a
sense no more efficient than to just
observe what actually happens in in real
life so to speak so this idea that okay
once we've got this model then we can
immediately kind of jump ahead and say
what will happen is is not the case
anymore and that's and sometimes one can
make
uh overall statements about well this
kind of a thing might happen
and um that uh or there are these
characteristics of what happens
okay so one of the things is very recent
last couple of months actually it's an
outgrowth of this big project that we've
had to understand the fundamental theory
of physics
is a kind of a new paradigm for modeling
that i kind of call the
multi-computational paradigm and uh let
me not get too deeply into it here but
basically the main point is that it's
it's a way of thinking about things in
which there isn't just a single thread
of time there's not just a rule that
says from this moment in time we work
out what will happen at the next moment
in time and so on there are multiple
threads of history and the rules
describe what happens on each thread of
history and each of these threads of
history they can branch there can be
multiple different things that can
happen at a particular moment or they
can merge they can turn out that
different sort of threads of history
lead to the same outcome and so on
the thing that's really interesting
about this multi-computational paradigm
is it seems to be a pretty good model it
seems to give you pretty good raw
material for modeling lots of kinds of
things and
it has the feature well it has a
necessary feature is if you say well
what happened in the system
there are all these different threads of
time you can't immediately say well this
is what happened instead you have to say
how an observer is sampling what's going
on in the system and it then turns out
that with sort of observers that are at
all like us
as kind of human observers there can be
certain very general features of the
behavior that you see in a
multi-computational system and that has
big consequences for understanding how
physics works but i also suspect it has
consequences in other places possibly in
places for understanding kind of the
evolution of society and things like
that they don't yet know exactly how
that will work out but one of the things
that that tends to suggest is that there
might be robust sort of laws people had
imagined back around 1800 or so
that just as people were figuring out
physics so they saw it at that time that
there would soon be a social physics
which was as much a predictive theory of
society as the physics of the time was a
predictive theory of the emotional
planets and things like that it didn't
work out that way
the question now is can one have
something which can make sort of
statements global statements about laws
that govern sort of things in in human
society for example and it might be that
that's the case but it will not be the
question is what are those laws about
in it's not they're not going to be
about the specifics of so then this
particular event will happen
they're not going to be about uh
that what they might be about might be
things where we might say well that's a
weird feature of society which we never
thought to think about before and yes
there might be a law about that thing
but
and then given that there is a law about
that thing a a way of
saying what will happen a way of
describing what will happen and so on
then perhaps we can use that to to build
just as we have we built lots of
engineering around the things that we
can predict will happen particularly
coming from the mathematical paradigm so
we might imagine doing similar kinds of
things in society but it's a um
uh
i think um
that
the general problem is is a complicated
one because
well
a particularly notable feature of models
about how humans behave
is
how does it how
are those models affected by the fact
that humans can know about the models
about humans how humans behave
one of the things i've always found
surprising
is if you look at things like the
behavior of people on the web you know
clicking on things they click here they
click there they you know they have
certain time distributions between when
they click on this and when they click
on that
a lot of those results if you look at it
in the aggregate for a large number of
people are incredibly precise they're
incredibly precise curves nobody can
really say why they come out the way
they come out but they're very they're
very robust and repeatable about kind of
the the behavior of people on the web so
there's some aspect of our behavior that
is in some at least statistical sense
quite predictable
but if you if you kind of um
uh
if you ask
um
yes i mean there there are things like
that there are kind of small scale
things like that that are predictable if
you say
uh
if you look at different areas that
involve oh yeah i was going to say in
the in the financial area it's a sort of
classic example
of where
uh people say oh look i've noticed this
regularity in the stock market or
something and they're they feel very
pleased they've noticed this regularity
and they say well given that regularity
i can make money by knowing that i can
make some small prediction about the
stock market and therefore i can use
that by some clever piece of financial
engineering to be able to make money
from the stock market
and what tends to happen is that once
somebody's discovered that and other
people notice they've discovered it then
things change in the market and it
prevents that ever working again now
having said that there are plenty of
people uh
people including people i know who've
who have been in the quantitative
finance world who have had particular
schemes for kind of beating the market
and they have kept working for a very
long time partly because sometimes the
the sort of technological foundation
that you need to execute those schemes
is large enough that even if somebody
else said oh i know how that scheme
works they wouldn't actually be able to
do it
but that's a place where sort of knowing
that the kind of the the the knowing the
humans knowing
what the what the theories are about how
the humans behave can have an effect on
how the humans behave although it
doesn't seem to have an effect at the
level of you know how quickly do we
click on things and so on but it may
have an effect at the level of more
global scale now of course in a sense
if it is to have an effect
one of the main ways it will have an
effect is through the fact that people
know enough about history to know gosh
if this is happening in the world then
if we don't do this this is inevitably
going to happen because gosh it's
happened 10 times before in history that
way
and so it's sort of an interesting and
strange thing
when people say oh history's irrelevant
we don't care about history you know the
world is is now in a special place it's
never been like this before for one
reason or another um you know let's
forget about history that's in a sense
denying even the thinnest thread of
possible kind of understanding of the of
the progression of how things work in in
the world and i i would tend to think
that in a sense the denial of history
you might think
that
you would say we don't need history to
understand the future of the world
we
can just do that with science but
actually the first step
in doing that science
might be to just say well what's the
history of what's happened i mean that's
the first kind of stage of of doing
scientific things is to say well you
know what are what's happened before
it's it's some and and that gives us
some expectation about what will happen
in the future
long answer to that
um
oh you guys are asking
complicated questions
um
okay there's a question here from cutoff
what knowledge helps weather prediction
and how
um
weather prediction is a question of
of maybe i think i've talked about this
actually once before maybe i should
refer to the previous time i've talked
about this i think i did to spend some
time talking about weather prediction so
let me let me skip that for for the time
um for the time being
uh
let's see
um
my gosh there's a question from aaron
to me
about when i count in my head do i count
verbally or visually or in some other
way
you know i don't know i always used to
think when i was a kid that i was
totally dis-numerate that i just
couldn't
do things with actual numbers because i
definitely would have a habit and still
do have a habit of like counting on my
fingers
i suppose one of the things that one
learns and perhaps having spent a lot of
time dealing with computers
and uh writing computational language
and so on
is how to not make mistakes when one
does things
you know computers are a great
sort of place to learn how to not make
mistakes
because if you write a piece of code and
it's slightly wrong
it's going to do the wrong thing
and you know if you wrote a piece of
english for example and it's sort of
slightly wrong well people still might
understanding it might kind of be okay
but when you write a piece of
computational language code
um and it
says the thing that's different from
what you wanted it to say it will do the
wrong thing
and so it's been something that i've
i've certainly noticed about myself is
is how do i do things slowly and
carefully enough that i just don't make
any mistakes
because typically the experience is once
you've made a mistake fixing the mistake
is always vastly harder than not making
the mistake in the first place and you
know once you made the mistake it's like
oh then you go and you do a whole bunch
of other things you spend hours doing
things on the basis of this thing that
turned out to be wrong so you know when
i'm writing code and things like that i
tend to like to you know every little
tiny fragment of this you know symbolic
program that i'm writing i'll just run
it see what it does does it do the right
thing okay i go on i assemble another
piece okay assemble another piece and
and gradually sort of slowly build it up
and i think sometimes uh
you know people might might watch me do
this and it might seem sort of painfully
slow and deliberate
but that's partly because over time i've
learned that there's certain kinds of
things don't do that too fast because
you'll get it wrong or at least i'll get
it wrong
um and so it's like okay i really want
to know how many of this thing there are
okay let me count very carefully and
deliberately and i'll sort of group
things in groups of five or something
and then i'll add the things up in my
head and so on um and it's it's uh it's
kind of a a laborious process but i i
think i tend to be a count on my fingers
type type person or at least
verbally say things not a um
not something very very visual although
i do tend to like to sort of group
things so that i can know oh that's a
group of five and i know it's really a
group of five and that's another group
of five and i can add them together and
so on i mean this this challenge of not
making mistakes
is um
uh i mean one has to not be absolutely
obsessive about it because then one ends
up not sort of being able to do things
at all but it's still
something where i think an important
issue is to know when to have a good
sense of whether you are pretty sure
you're right
whether oh there's a possibility i made
a mistake here and um uh you know i
think
that comes a lot when it's question of
understanding things and i i think over
time i've gotten progressively better at
understanding when i understand things
and understanding when i'm that's still
a little bit loose i don't really quite
understand it so if you ask me something
about it i can't necessarily tell you
the right answer
um
the uh
so let's see
um
rj is commenting if you write enough
errors in code that cancel each other
out perfectly your code is perfect
it's it's very hard to have errors that
cancel out in that sense
because
once your code is doing something it
will do something in one place
it will you know maybe
it will
i mean i suppose you can have a
situation where oh you thought you were
generating a list of numbers let's say
but actually sometimes it can be a list
with no elements in it
and okay that's a that's a thing and one
might think oh that could
make something go wrong but maybe
later on you know and oh you're going to
make a picture based on these things but
if the list of numbers has no elements
in it the picture is going to look goofy
but then it turns out that later on you
filter the pictures based on this or
that thing and so even if there was one
goofy one that would be dropped out when
you filter them and so that error is
kind of washed away um i i think that is
a
my impression is that that's a very rare
case where things are kind of um
robust enough
where things kind of um
get to the point where they're kind of
smoothed over by something later on i
mean i tend to think you know having
spent a lot of my life doing design of
computational language design
the real job of the language designer
is to make a language where people
typically write correct code
and if the language is confusing
people will often write wrong code if
the language is doesn't give you enough
kind of
framework about how to think about
things
people will end up doing very
complicated things where where things
can go wrong i mean for example
if you're writing low level if you're
writing in a standard low-level
programming language you're often
writing you know a loop that says for
this variable equals this you know do
this add something to the variable add
this to the thing you're working on et
cetera et cetera et cetera it's really
one step at a time and if you make any
mistake in any of those steps
the whole thing's toast
and you know in kind of our wolfram
language um one of the things we try to
do is to take the kind of cognitive
lumps that you think about things in
terms of and make those be the things
that you're using in the computational
language be have those be the things
that have names so like you have might
have a a name like table make a table of
values of a thing
and rather than oh let's take this
variable and add something to it and
append things to make this list et
cetera et cetera et cetera it's like
there's this one thought that is a clear
thought that we can have oh i want to
make a make a table of these things and
you can have that thought you can
immediately get the computer to do it
you're not fiddling down in the details
where there's a lot more possibility of
error you're rather taking kind of your
thoughts now now of course the computer
can can force you in when you try and
represent something in computational
language if you don't know what you're
talking about
then the computer is going to catch you
out
because when you write something in
computational language it is a definite
thing that you're saying and if you're
kind of vague if you kind of wave your
hands as i'm waving my hands right now
and so to say it roughly works like this
that's kind of not good enough
it's actually very much the same with
mathematics and mathematical notation if
you write sort of precise mathematical
notation you kind of have to commit
yourself to oh it's it's defined this
way it's not like oh it's vaguely this
or that now i have to say that there are
plenty of times in thinking about things
where saying it's vaguely this or that
is a place where sort of human intuitive
thinking is is very important and allows
you to just leap over uh huge amounts of
detail that can in some cases get filled
in later i mean one of the things in
terms of thinking about things
is one thing is you go one step at a
time you're always you know you always
know what you're doing everything's very
precise to define but you're walking one
small step at a time and to get a big
distance is a lot of steps
the other alternative is you have an
intuitive grasp of how things will work
and you jump a thousand miles
in front
and you figure out this is roughly how
it has to work
that can be extremely important to do
that because once you've done that it's
much easier to go through those detailed
steps and go in that direction because
you at least know what direction you're
going in otherwise you're taking these
detailed steps and oh you might make a
wrong turn and then you're taking these
detailed steps off in another direction
you don't know what's happening so for
me it's very important to have this kind
of intuitive ideas about how things
should work out
and then it's it's great to be able to
particularly have a have a computer fill
in the details and so when i think about
things i might think in in sort of
general terms about something and then i
say well how will i turn that into a
computational language representation
and that process of turning things into
a computational language representation
is one where kind of a lot of issues
that i was so vague about get nailed
down
let's see
um
there's a
question or comment here from jonah
um
how do we improve our inductions towards
producing creative results in science
are scientific inductions probabilistic
how can i how lucky can i get with an
induction towards the proof of a thing
so so what is scientific induction it's
kind of an idea
that
um
okay so so
why is there science at all
the fundamentally it's because there's
order in the universe there are definite
regularities and laws that govern how
the universe works it's not self-evident
that the universe should be that way
it's not obvious that the universe
should be at all comprehensible to us
that it should have that it should be
possible for us to describe the universe
in terms of comparatively simple laws
for how things work it's not obvious
that every time we drop something you
know it falls under gravity in the same
way it could be that every time you drop
something some detailed difference
happens
you know if you look at i don't know
you're um looking at the ocean and
you're asking you know when i put
something on the surface of the ocean
how will it move well every time you put
it down there it's probably going to
move slightly differently because
there's a slightly different piece of
swell or there's a little wave that's
different or something like that it
could be that everything about how the
world works would be such that there
wouldn't be a global law that describes
it it would always be special case
specific example etc the fact that there
is regularity in the universe is a very
fundamental thing it's a very
fundamental kind of philosophical
theological whatever point about the
about the universe that there is
regularity in it now i have to say that
in recent times i have come to believe
that the reason there's regularity in
the universe at least as we perceive it
is because of the way that we perceive
it
that underneath ultimately the universe
is not a very regular place the universe
is a place where sort of in some sense
all possible things happen
but the way that we sample the universe
and the way that we uh
kind of the way that we we choose to
knit together our perceptions of what's
going on kind of is what leads us to
these kind of comparatively simple laws
for the universe and so in a sense our
our the nature of our consciousness
is what leads us to believe that the
universe follows simple laws and we
could if we were some alien
consciousness or something we could end
up with a completely different set of
laws that the universe should follow and
i think in fact there are really two
sort of axiomatic features of us that
lead us to conclude that the universe
follows simple laws
one is that we are computationally
bounded that is if we want to know every
detail about what's happening in the
universe where every gas molecule in the
room is going all those kinds of things
we don't do that we we don't our brains
our minds are just not capable of
following all those details and doing
all those computations we are
computationally bounded we we have to
summarize things in simpler ways so
that's one sort of feature the second
feature that turns out to be pretty
important
is the idea that we believe that there
is a single thread of time in the
universe
that is that sort of we can remember the
past we can go into the future there is
a single thread of of history that we're
following that we're not saying oh there
are these different things that happen
and then they merge together and so on
now in in some sense in reality in the
universe i'm pretty sure that there are
all these many threads of time and so on
it's just that our sampling of the
universe doesn't
doesn't notice that and in fact when
whenever there are things which are
following these multiple threads we are
conflating these things together and
that's just our way of sampling what
happens in the universe and that's a
that's a sort of crucial feature of of
how things work in the universe i mean
something somewhat related to this idea
of sequentialization and time is things
like the possibility of motion
the possibility that even though the
microscopic structure of the universe is
different here and here it's still the
case that i can move my hand from here
to here and i think of it as the same
hand that wound up in the second place
in the first place even though at a
microscopic level if one looked down at
the sort of level of the atoms of space
in our models of physics and so on they
will be different atoms of space when my
hand is here and when my hand is here
nevertheless
for our purposes at the level of of of
understanding of the universe that we
have we consider those the same
and those are those are things that are
sort of our way of parsing the universe
so our way of understanding um how
things work in the universe and i think
that's what leads us to conclude that
the universe follows fairly simple laws
fellow has a certain kind of regularity
it's a kind of selfish self-fulfilling
self-inflicted conclusion but anyway the
end result is so the universe follows
comparatively simple laws there are you
know you set up more or less the same
circumstances more or less the same
things will happen all those kinds of
good things
so that is really the basis for science
if it wasn't that way it would be you
would just have to say
well the universe chooses to do this
this today and chooses to do something
different tomorrow and we can't really
make a general formal scientific
statement about what the universe does
okay but when we want to make a formal
scientific statement about what the
universe does
how do we conclude what that statement
is how do we decide what the universe is
really doing
well
the only tool we have generally thought
that we have to determine what the
universe is really doing underneath is
experiments
we say let's try doing this now let's
try dropping this this ball now let's
try dropping this other thing now let's
see what happens okay we do it ten times
um well
then we say it always does the same
thing let's characterize how it works
okay it follows this particular law of
motion so then we can say okay we've
seen it do it 10 times
gosh that must be the way it works
and that's the notion of scientific
induction if we've done it the
experiment a certain number of times
then we can conclude that really is how
the universe works
and we can then uh sort of
extrapolate from that to say okay
whenever we do this experiment it'll
always work the same way there's nothing
unexpected and miraculous that could
happen it's just a sort of a a
repeatable scientific idea
so
it's um
um
when you ask the question
given a a small amount of data 10
observations
what can you conclude from those 10
observations can you conclude it always
works this way well of course you can't
conclude it always works that way you
only got 10 observations
the only way you could conclude
something more global than from those 10
observations is if you have a sort of
uber theory a theory that tells you
about the set of possible theories you
might have because for example if you
say my theory has to be described by a
mathematical formula that is of this
type and it's it roughly looks like this
then you can make much more definite
conclusions from just making 10
observations
let's say you've got a coin you're
flipping it
and
it
and you have and you say
my coin is described by having a certain
probability a certain independent
probability of coming up heads or tails
and then you flip the coin ten times and
nine times it comes up heads
well then it's a sort of exercise in
statistics mathematical statistics to
work out what is the probability given
that that the coin has
uh 50 50 heads or tails intrinsic
probability what's the probability that
it has 75 25 uh intrinsic probability
and so on given the observation you
invert it typically using a beza's
theorem to say given what i observed
what does that imply about what the
underlying actual probabilities were
now the catch is that unless you have
some a priori unless you have some
initial sort of uber theory you could
never answer that question you have to
have that initial kind of uber theory
about how the world could possibly be
and and the distribution of
possibilities what the likelihood is
that the world for example is governed
by a law that involves five parameters
versus ten parameters versus whatever
else you need that kind of uber theory
in order to make a conclusion from a
limited observation once you have that
kind of uber theory then yes you can say
there's this probability that this is
the correct specific theory this
probability this is the correct specific
theory and so on now what's happened in
the course of people doing science and
methodologies and science and so on is
people are always coming out with and
now we have a modelless prediction a a a
non-parametric it's often called not
involving let's say a specific not
involving some existing formula where
you're just tweaking parameters it's a
non-parametric a just
from it's just
it will just find the theory based on
the data without any uber theory without
any prior assumption about how the
theory works
every such claim is a fake
and
that people regularly ever every few
years there'll be another reason why
somebody says and now we can do it this
way so the most recent one of those is
with neural networks
people say
oh
we can just use a neural net with
machine learning and so on to say let's
look at this data and let's work out a
model that will be encoded in the neural
network for this data and it's a
non-parametric it's a model-less model
so to speak
but it's not
it is if you look at the
what a neural net of a certain size and
so on what kind of what kind of
characterization of the world can it
give
there's a certain characterization it
can give if i used a different shaped
neural net so to speak with more layers
of of computation or whatever else i
would be able to represent a different
set of things in the world
it's even though people say i've got
such a general model underneath it's
really a model this model that i've got
here it's never true it is necessarily
the case that there is always an
underlying model an uber model whatever
however you want to position it so to
speak there's always a more global thing
of which your particular model is
supposed to be some instance
and and so one can start asking
well
you know what's the best uber model that
we can have
now this is where it gets a little bit
interesting because in the past those
uber models tended to be very
mathematical models they will be things
like a very common type with so-called
general linear models
which are just you know straight line
dependents of this and that and and uh
mathematical formulas basically
um or you might have some some other
simple mathematical formula it might be
a gaussian distribution a particular e
to the minus x squared distribution that
is a pretty common thing to to occur and
then you tweak the parameters of that
so
those are the you know sort of typical
models for things and why should those
models work well for example in the case
of gaussian
gaussian
the
gaussian
distribution here there's the following
fact it's a basic fact in mathematical
statistics it's called the central limit
theorem and it says the following
if you
are
randomly picking values
let's say the values between zero and
one
okay so you get point two point seven
point three point four you just pick a
bunch of those values and you pick them
at random
according with some different with some
probability for each value for each of
those possible values to occur in
between zero and one okay if you take
more than i don't know five maybe ten of
those values
and you just look at the average of
those values
you say i'm going to take buckets of
five values ten values i'm going to just
look at the average of that bucket of
values
that
average
is distributed according to this
gaussian distribution with quite high
accuracy in other words whenever you
take averages it ends up being the case
that you get this kind of bell-shaped
distribution where the most likely value
of the average is kind of in the middle
and where there's a progressively lower
chance of getting values further off in
the tails and you get this kind of bell
curve distribution where where it's
known that you know in if they're
different
many many details of that curve are very
commonly talked about things like
confidence intervals
um
two sigma
standard deviations all kinds of other
other sorts of characteristics of that
curve are widely talked about the reason
that curve is so widely talked about is
because if you just take a bunch of
numbers and you're always taking
averages that'll be what you typically
get now there are footnotes to the
central limit theorem the footnotes are
about well exactly how are those numbers
initially picked and how how are those
numbers distributed could there be a
really huge number that isn't between
zero and one that's as big as a hundred
could there be an unboundedly large
number things like that there are a
bunch of footnote conditions to the
central limit theorem which in in
practice in the real world often sink it
or for example another one would be oh
the numbers can be
anything but if they go below zero
you're toast you know if you go below
zero let's say you're looking at the
price of a stock if it's below zero and
the company is worth a negative amount
of money that doesn't happen that way
the company is bankrupt at that point
and so it's it's so so that that changes
the way this distribution works
so in any case the the um
uh
this idea
of um what is the correct sort of um
uh ultimate
model model for the world
is an important one and people have
sometimes thought this is particularly
prevalent in medical research that
everything is a gaussian distribution it
just has to be it's not true simply not
true i mean for example if you look at
the distribution of human heights
it is
uh generally
uh well i have to say i haven't looked
at this data for a while but but um it
used to be the case at least that human
heights were pretty accurately gaussian
distributed nobody really knows why it's
presumably the effect of many genes that
have an effect on height and you're sort
of taking their linear average like that
but nobody really quite knows why that
is if you look even at human weights
they are not gaussian distributed
they're not distributed according to the
spell distribution they're distributed
according to the skewed distribution
that has a bigger tail and if you look
at i don't know medical test results of
different kinds you'll find all sorts of
distributions that are sometimes normal
distribution sometimes gaussian
distribution but often not
and quite a lot of the statistics in in
local research is based on the
assumption of gaussian distributions
and you know people often quote these p
values and things like that that's all
based on maybe i'll explain it some
other time it's all based on features of
this gaussian distribution this normal
distribution
uh which just aren't always correct
okay but so the question is is there a
best model model for how things work in
the world
and you know if one's going to just sort
of fit things to some model model what's
the best way to do that well there are
two ways i can imagine sort of anchoring
that one is to know how physics really
works underneath
and the other is to know how we work
in terms of our way of perceiving things
so in terms of how physics works
underneath i think one of the great
achievements of our physics project in
the last couple of years has been
getting a pretty good understanding of
what the machine code of the universe
looks like
and from that it's a long way from you
know what's happening at the you know a
trillion trillion internal engineering
trillionth of a meter size in space time
to what happens in everyday life
but it gives us some foundation for
thinking about sort of what is the
ultimate model for things in the world
and the one thing it tells us very
clearly is that computational models
are ultimately the way the whole
universe is put together now whether it
could be there's a computational model
that works at that trillion trillion
trillionth scale
but that isn't the right model at a
large scale but it seems like it is it
is pretty good evidence that this
computational model idea is a good idea
from the fact that it really works at
that machine code type level okay so
that's one kind of model so the other
kind of thing is about our perception of
the world how do we perceive the world
what do we even notice in the world well
what we notice in the world is is
largely determined by how our brains are
set up so for example when we look
around at a visual scene we tend to
break that visual scene into objects we
say there's a camera there there's a
computer there there's a you know
whatever it is there
um and
rather than we have this notion of sort
of clumping things into objects
well
that's a feature of the way our visual
system and our brains work
and so
when we start saying well how does
you know what should we make science
about
we will start saying well there's this
object and another object another thing
that does this and does that we notice
the things that our brains are able to
perceive there may be other details
about how the world is working that we
just don't notice because our brains are
not wired to perceive those things so
when it comes to making models if our
models are sort of plugged into the way
that brains our brains perceive things
then that's a good step leg up in terms
of having a model that reproduces those
aspects of the world that we're likely
to care about
so in other words the and and that kind
of is probably why
when we look at things like neural
networks
for machine learning why they're not so
terrible at making models of some kinds
of things
like for example i don't know the
folding of proteins or whatever else
they're not so terrible and the reason
they're not so terrible
is less to do with the underlying
physics and more to do with the what we
care about about what's happening in the
physics because those are the things
that we have been choosing to look at
we're not choosing to look at the
detailed dynamics of the microscopic
motions of the proteins and this that
the other rather we're just interested
in what overall shape is the thing going
to make and that's something that is
more uh you know sort of uh something
that more operates at the level that our
brains operate at and that's i think a a
slight argument for why
there is a little bit of a leg up to
models that are based on the same kinds
of things that our perception is based
on so that's a that's kind of a um so if
you're if you're asking how do you get
to do scientific induction better
i think there are those two anchor
points one is kind of what the
fundamental machine code of the universe
looks like and the other is what we know
about how we perceive things and what is
worth including in a model to be able to
say the universe works this way at least
as far as we will perceive it there may
be many details to how the universe
works
that are wonderful and and very rich and
complicated but they just we don't
happen to perceive them so it's not so
important to capture them in a model
that we make
and by the way i i
thank you for asking that question
because quite a lot of what i had to say
there uh was a clarification to
um
let's see there's a question couple of
questions about flipping coins here
from techno which side of a quarter has
better aerodynamics and from rift tracks
if a quarter was flipped by a human
a hundred thousand times in a windy day
another hundred thousand times a
non-windy day with the overall outcome
still be 50 50.
well look here's the point
uh
you know if you have a machine that
flips coins
and
the air is still
you can make a very repeatable
experiment you can flip it with a
certain velocity when it's flipped from
the artificial finger so to speak and
it'll go flipping around in the air if
the air is still and the air is in the
same state every time the the the you
know the coin will turn over a certain
number of times and then go and land on
heads or tails and it will be completely
predictable
there's nothing that makes that
unpredictable now the reason that coin
flipping seems kind of random
is because even the slightest difference
in the speed that the coin is made to go
up at will cause the number of times the
coin turns around in the air to be off
by one and off by one is enough to go
from heads to tails
so that it's it's because
there is
uh let's say it turns over 20 times in
the air
then in a rough approximation if you
change the speed with which you you know
you flip up the coin by one by by five
percent because your finger is not
accurately producing the same force to
within five percent you won't be able to
determine whether the coin will land up
heads or tails so in a sense what's
happening in coin flipping is you're
kind of being sensitive to the initial
conditions being sensitive to the
precise speed that you flip the coin out
and you're also being sensitive to the
environmental conditions like was there
a a puff of wind that uh you know moved
the coin slightly this way or that way
so the fact that you say oh coin
flipping is random is really because the
the thing that's doing the flipping you
haven't completely determined how that
works
because we just don't have that level of
precision but if it was a machine that
was carefully machined and so on and all
carefully set up then you could make it
completely predictable
and i think uh
this question about which side of court
has better aerodynamics and i don't know
whether how accurately when you flip
coins
uh you know let's say
um
you ask the question as you change the
it's a slightly tricky question remember
actually i i did write some stuff about
this in my new kind of science book and
some in some one of the thousand notes
at the back of the book one of them is
about coin flipping um and i did talk
about this question about
uh when
what it even means let's say you say as
you change the speed that you flip the
coin at and you you can make a plot
there's even a picture in the book there
of um of what happens um there's the
sort of black and white stripes
according to whether the coin is going
to land up heads or tails based on the
speed at which you flip the coin now
it's a pretty tricky thing
what what you mean by oh i'm going to
flip it randomly because you've got
well it's just you know it's not random
between zero speed zero and the speed of
light that's definitely what not what
you mean you mean there's a certain sort
of typical range of speeds and exactly
what that distribution is like is going
to determine the exact probabilities of
different things happening
because it isn't the case that the coin
flips 100 000 times in the air it flips
maybe 20 times i don't know how many um
i think when i was was working on this
back 25 years ago or more i actually did
try and um i unfortunately we didn't
have cell phone cameras and things like
that when it made it a lot easier back
in those days to actually do the kind of
freeze frame photography to see just how
many times does it flip over
but um uh
let's see
um
it's a question from
[Music]
wst
um
how do you end up with a different set
of rules while describing a system of
definite observable behavior
no matter how alien a consciousness is
the rules will remain the same
well
yes
the rules for what
underneath happens might remain the same
the question is what do you care about
in what happens
so really classic example that i keep on
referring back to and it actually
strangely enough it was the the version
of this question was what really got me
first seriously interested in
fundamental physics
50 years ago now um back when i was like
12 years old or something um and uh
here's the thing
we see you know we have gas molecules
bouncing around in the room
we say
what do we care about about the dynamics
of a gas
maybe we just care about the overall
pressure maybe we care about the the
velocity the speed of the gas you know
we
move our hand through the gas and it's
moving out in in certain directions and
so on what do we care about
there is many many many details about
how these gas molecules are bouncing
around and so on but most of the things
that happen we don't care about
so when we talk about a sort of an alien
consciousness representing something in
a different way what we may be talking
about is the fact that there is a
different set of things that have been
perceived and so there are different
laws that govern those kinds of things
because we have certain laws that govern
pressure and temperature but if we make
up i don't know
uh
uh
uglurfness
made up by some alien you know
uglurifeness
is will be some
characteristic of the details of of
molecular motions that we would say we
don't we don't care about that we don't
measure that we don't see why that's
important but to the aliens that's the
most important thing about the gas and
it will have different laws and so
that's how you end up with these very
different descriptions of what is at
some level quotes the same thing
let's see
uh
that's a question about how the spell
the word that i just made up sorry i
just made that word up it didn't come
with a spelling
i mean the uh it's an interesting that
the story of how you spell words is
always an interesting one you know in
different languages some languages are
phonetically spelled as in
the way the word sounds you can
immediately deduce how the word will be
spelled some of the languages like
russian which which had a a a definite
written language constructed sort of in
recorded history um uh you know were
were set up that way from the beginning
english we weren't so lucky from a
spelling point of view there were a
bunch of bright ideas back in the middle
ages where people said let's when we
write a word let's encode something of
the meaning of the word write in the
word in its spelling even though we
don't say that
and you know for somebody like me who's
done computational language design for a
long time these kinds of oh that was a
bright idea about how to encode meaning
and so on i always pay attention to
these things and uh i wonder if it was
right or not i mean a classic example i
don't know the word det in english spelt
d-e-b-t
where's the b we don't say the b
well back in the day it had been spelt
d-e-t-t
but somebody people decided to add the b
because it was like the latin word
debator which um has the b in it and
which means the right thing it's like
let's encode the meaning in the spelling
of the word even though
the um uh even though the um
uh we're not going to say that that
those letters when we say the word and
that's
not for that decision probably spelling
bees would be a lot less interesting in
in english um because one would have
potentially a a um a purely phonetic way
in which words are spelled and even the
standardization of spelling is a
comparatively recent phenomenon i mean i
think last 100 150 years i think you see
the the sort of full standardization of
spelling and you go back further than
that definitely not a standardization
even even among you know people's names
that somebody will spell it one one way
one time another way another time and
maybe that's because they only said
their name and some other scribe or
something wrote it down and one time
they transcribed it one way and one time
they transcribed it another way so i
think but this question about um uh
it's it's an interesting question what
um
um
well actually the general question of
what makes a reasonable word is an
interesting one i've certainly thought
about this question in connection with
things like naming products naming areas
of science things like this
uh and you know the frustrating thing i
always find is that when you make up
words for things sometimes the words are
really obvious
and you immediately come up with them
like for example a word that i recently
started using as ruleology the study of
systems with simple rules
and that's kind of an obvious name
ruliology for studying things with rules
but i've been thinking about what that
thing should be called for 30 years and
i've come up with a lot of different
possibilities that are based on latin
and greek and so on
and uh unfortunately in the area of
things like rules and structure and
and sort of autonomous behavior and so
on most of those words have been used
for things we know well like logos as
you know used for logic logistics uh you
know all these kinds of things um and
and all the all
lodgy type
type fields or something like uh you
know rules i think greek arc archon
archos
or that's more a ruler in greek
but that leads us to archaeology and
archetype and all these other arc words
that um uh you know archaeology would
have been a great name for the study of
rules based on greek meaning of words
were not already taken for the study of
ancient uh ancient artifacts and so on
um i don't actually know quite how it
got how the ancient artifacts version of
archaeology got that meaning i i would
have liked to have that meaning but i
was uh 500 years too late for that
um
but so it is a it's a curious question
what makes a word sound reasonable and
not sound reasonable be memorable not be
memorable and so on we certainly know
that there's a certain amount of
regularity in the structure of words i
mean from from there are certain
combinations of letters that occur more
often there's certain combinations of
sounds that occur more often there are
some fashions in what kinds of sounds
might be good ones to occur i mean the
use of x
in english you know they're an endless
product names that are from the last 50
years or so that are x based product
names although one of the early ones
xerox
strangely that particular one
its x was not added uh for sporting
value so to speak in the sense that it
wasn't put there as a matter of just
like like let's exit up in a in a um
kind of because x is a cool letter uh
zero
xerox came from the name xerography
which was the the process of of dry it
was kind of a greek
named version of of so
a photocopier a um of that type uh was
based on xerography and that comes from
a greek the greek word uh
which which means dry and graphy which
means writing so it was kind of a a dry
writing thing i mean just
okay for the sake of having a technology
moment here um it's like how does a
laser printer work how does a how does a
photocopier work
um it uses
the fact that um
the uh
um gosh it's a long time since i thought
about this
um so
the uh
it uses the fact that
you can
have
a um
uh
a plate used to be made of selenium i'm
not sure if they're still made of
selenium and it has the following
property that
you can uh have it be the case that
the
you can
where light falls on this plate
there will be uh you are um causing it
to electrically conduct and where it
doesn't fall it doesn't electrically
conduct um and so so what so then the
idea is that you you have the image from
your
piece of paper or the thing you're
trying to print or whatever else
and that
is that if it's from a piece of paper it
will be actual light if it's a laser
printer it's a laser using its light to
scan across the plate
and um or it's usually a drum in in
actuality that the thing is usually is a
cylindrical drum but conceptually it's a
plate
um
and uh and then in some places where the
light falls electricity is conducted
and the charge you you charge up this
plate and in places where the light
falls it's discharged um so so it
doesn't have a um
so it doesn't have this electrical
charge okay so you have this plate which
has this complicated pattern of where
it's charged and where it's not and then
what you do is you get these plastic
granules
and you sort of sprinkle those plastic
granules on the plate and they stick in
places where it's charged and they don't
stick in places where it isn't charged
and that's the so-called toner that's
used in in laser printers and and uh
photocopiers and so on and that's what
and so what then is happening is in in
places where it sticks it's you know
it's it's got black or whatever else it
is then you put a piece of paper next to
that and you bake it on with heat
um and and that's how you how you
produce the image on the piece of paper
so that that's kind of the process of
both uh photocopying and um uh
and um
and laser printing laser printing again
instead of having the light from the
original image of the piece of paper
you're sort of synthesizing that image
by having a laser that's scanning across
the the the plate or the drum and it's
it's kind of it's kind of going one line
at a time to specify what the um uh what
the content should be there
the reason that it was sort of xerox and
so on was was proud of the dry
for uh dry copying um was that the
previous generation
uh
in my youth there used to be a variety
of copying technologies that involve
liquids and where you would do things
like um you would
expose a piece of paper that had some
kind of
it was more like a photographic process
where you will be essentially developing
it through this um uh through this
liquid and it was it was all a very
messy process with liquids and so on so
that was a that was sort of the big
innovation was of of dry copying
all right maybe one or two more and then
we should wrap up for
today
um
ah
okay rbs says why can't logic be easier
to understand
what i mean is all this academic stuff
that teaches logic it seems greek to to
the person who's who's saying this um
when i try to learn i get bored fast
because they explain it in a too
complicated way
well it's worth understanding logic has
various aspects i mean
the original idea of logic probably due
to aristotle
in
4th century bc roughly
was what aristotle was doing was when
people make arguments about things
somebody stands up and says you know the
people of athens must
go to war with sparta because
of this and that and the other and et
cetera et cetera et cetera they make an
argument they say if this is true and
that is true
if it's not true that this and that are
true
then blah blah blah then not this or not
that must be the case and you make these
arguments and the arguments have a
certain logical structure what aristotle
wanted to do was to classify those
logical structures to classify the
structure of arguments he'd been at
other times in his life he was
classifying you know molos types of
molluscs and things like this he was
very big on classifying things and in
his more philosophical work he was into
classifying causes of things and um uh
you know the the the material cause the
formal cause the uh
oh my gosh what's the other one there's
four of them the final one is the final
cause but i'm missing one of his causes
um but uh uh
there's a second cause i can't remember
what that is um
but uh in any case you know just
classifying kinds of things but one of
the things he classified was forms of
argumentation
so that became a type of logic called
syllogistic logic
that
for
more than a thousand years
was taught to people who were supposed
to be being educated
and people taught a little bit of
mathematics they taught rhetoric and
they along with that they talked taught
logic
and it was kind of neck and neck with
mathematics as a thing that was taught
and people would memorize these forms of
argument
they actually had had mnemonics like i
think one was called barbara another was
called celerent
and those those letters stood for
particular structures of argument and
you could kind of memorize oh if i make
it this and that and whatever so then in
the in the 1830s
it became a lot more mathematical george
boole particularly kind of figured out
how you can really think about it in
terms of and and or not
and
really just think about things more like
mathematical variables p means
is it raining or not p can be either
true or false
uh q means do i have an umbrella or not
and then you kind of can make things
that go together
p and q things like that a person who
did a lot of work in kind of
sort of popularizing um
uh logic
uh symbolic logic this idea of you know
ps and q's standing for statements about
the world was charles dodson uh better
known as lewis carroll author of
analysts in wonderland and so on but he
also wrote rather nice books about logic
um trying to sort of uh give everyday in
versions of this kind of
this kind of way of describing things in
terms of logic now the fact is that way
of describing things in terms of logic
with our mathematics and our computers
we can crush it
if you give any kind of combination of
not p and q or r and not p and this and
that and the other you give this very
very complicated thing we can be very
precise and say this is the truth table
of what whether the result will be true
if all these different inputs are true
or false so we can take that whole
expression and we can simplify it or we
can say is there any set of truth values
for the inputs that will make the whole
thing true etc etc etc it's a decidable
mathematical theory it's something where
there is a systematic procedure for
answering the question uh you know how
will this work how does this how does
that work in logic so that style of
logic so-called propositional logic a
logic of propositions like it is raining
today that kind of logic is something
that with our modern mathematics and
computers and so on we've completely
nailed it we understand everything about
how it works
the
the um and from a human point of view
it's
how useful is it in actuality of of
tracking arguments as aristotle wanted
it to be it's mildly useful uh people
make the most horrendous mistakes
in not thinking kind of logically like
that but i would say that the more
elaborate forms of logic
are more relevant because they are the
way that switching circuits out of which
computers and other things are made they
work according to logic where they're a
little uh you know a gate a transistor
implements a single logical operation
usually a nor operation um and uh you
know we'll have one might have a billion
of those things all put together that
actually does what our cpu chips do and
so on but that was sort of the form of
logic propositional logic was kind of
the earliest form of logic there's
another form of logical predicate logic
that's a little bit more elaborate
invented well it began to be invented in
1600s but got serious in the work of
people like got love fragra in the end
of the 1800s
it was it's the idea of saying rather
than p is a proposition p and q blah
blah of having these so-called
quantifiers
things that say for all
so let's say
all
uh the most famous one uh you know all
men immortal socrates is a man therefore
socrates is mortal
that's well that's actually in the form
of syllogism but the for all uh
uh
it's true for all something that this
works there are two quantifiers that one
usually uses for all and there exists so
you might say
um
uh for all sheep
it's true that they're white
and then you might ask does there exist
a black sheep and then you could sort of
prove that from one thing that the other
thing is not is not true there are no
black sheep etc etc etc um you know
logic by the way has the feature that
whatever you put into it is what you get
out of it so if it turns out that
actually you know i don't think it was
when in australia when australia was was
when people went to australia and
noticed that there were you know people
said all swans are white until they went
to australia when they turned out to be
a black swan there i think that's the
story and um
the uh uh and you know sheep have
different colors and so on but you might
have only seen white sheep and it's like
that scientific induction question um
the uh
um you know can you cut from the fact
you've seen a hundred white sheep can
you conclude that every sheep is white i
mean it's like there's this uh there's
this story told it's kind of a uh a
story told with various kinds of um
um uh
of scientists in the story and i think a
a common version of the story is like
there are three
science types on a train
somehow in scotland i don't know why in
scotland was part of this but but then
they see a sheep out of the window and
there's an economist
and the economist is a very generalizing
scientist who says oh so it must be the
case that you know all sheep in scotland
are white because we've seen this one
white sheep
and the uh the physicist says well all
we can say is that there's this one
sheep that that's um uh that's white and
the much more precise mathematician then
says no actually all we can say is that
one side of one sheep is white
um but of course uh
and you know this is a question of you
know how far can you take the scientific
induction and in different fields there
are different uh expectations for
different kinds of modeling and so on
that get done about how far you can do
that um but uh
let's see i was i was talking about
logic um and uh just to sort of finish
that thought
the um
uh logic as i say what you get out is
just what you put in so for example a
very common feature in logic is the
logical implication function
in private in propositional logic
it's uh you know if p then q
okay
and one of the things that's absolutely
crazy in some ways is that in standard
logic
implication if p then q
has the feature that
if
p is false
then
for any q
one says that the implication is true
so from something that isn't true you
can infer anything that's a very weird
and screwy claim
that doesn't really accord with a lot of
things that we think of every day but
that's the way that the structure of
logic the propositional logic say things
should work so anyway so the logic is
usually propositional logic then
predicate logic and then you get into
different special forms of logic like
modal logic and temporal logic where you
have things about
you know things like about time
uh for all time it is true that whatever
for all times after this it is true that
whatever or logics where you say uh
there is a possibility that whatever or
sometimes a probabilistic logic it's
probable that whatever you can make
these various logical calculate and
there's a question of sort of how do
they agree with or not agree with our
everyday sense of how the world works in
a sense they're scientific models
they're like scientific models of um the
uh um
uh they're like kind of scientific
models
of every day of the everyday world
and they're not particularly good
scientific models of the everyday world
they're very good models if you're
building a computer that has you know
has uh transistors that act like precise
logical gates but if you say what does
this mean for sort of our overall
understanding of the world it's not that
good a model and and people have sort of
tried to build kind of physics reasoning
um uh kinds of of of of ways to
to uh to do things based on sort of just
making logical inferences about the
world and they really pale in comparison
to what you can do with sort of the the
more mathematical computational approach
to studying those kinds of things
um
the uh
but any case in terms of logic
the the other sort of mathematical logic
then kind of emerged from things like
predicate logic uh also emerged partly
as a as a way of representing
mathematics using logic
and that gets very obscure and
complicated and
there are many foundational questions
that uh that bite us in the design of
computational languages and things that
are also foundational questions in
mathematical logic having to do with oh
particularly
uh issues of reference
if you have in mathematical logic and in
in computational language they're things
like variables but there are all kinds
of issues about um you say
um
uh
i'm going to put a hat on the duck
okay then that's your function put a hat
on the duck
okay the problem is that you know the
question of which duck
well you have this thing this function
says put a hat on the duck and then the
question is well you know how do you
refer to which duck you're talking about
and how do you know it's that particular
duck the one that's called the gym
and um uh you know or it's that
particular and then it's well is that
enough to specify the duck and so on and
you get into these questions which are
sort of a a mixture of things about the
real world and things about kind of the
structure of a formal language that get
quite complicated and um and in fact are
quite unresolvable without some kind of
appeal to either what you're trying to
achieve or how the world actually works
outside
and and yes there are very obscure
things that happen if you uh
last december was the hundredth
anniversary of the invention of these
things called combinators which were a
great step forward in many ways in
mathematical logic
which have really not been well
understood they're certainly not widely
understood for a hundred years they've
not been widely understood i mean i
myself have made use of some aspects of
how they work in the design of our
computational language but if i tried to
explain that to people and that was the
how it works it's like an
incomprehensible thing i would say that
one feature of combinators the one thing
that i just makes them super hard to
understand is
they are a way of describing things
without using any nouns
they never name things
they always just say that thing over
there combined with this thing over here
combined with that thing that's first
there etc etc etc they're always just
specifying plumbing of how you get sort
of information flowing from here to
there but they never actually name a
thing they never say i'm going to call
it x
they just say
it's it's the thing that goes from here
goes to there goes to that et cetera et
cetera et cetera we humans
have a very hard time with this
and it's you know when you look at
combinator expressions that represent in
a sense this plumbing of of take this
data from here to there and then do this
with it it's really incomprehensible to
us humans and i've certainly been
curious whether there's a way to kind of
make scaffolding in human language that
gets to the point where that's
comprehensible i haven't succeeded in
doing that
um
that's okay i should i should really uh
go here
um all right there are some interesting
questions maybe we can start with them
um
next time
all right well uh
thanks for
lots of interesting questions and um
i look forward to doing this again next
week